welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today you
know earlier this week one of my
favorite reports of the entire year came
out and I know it sounds a little weird
to have a favorite report but this is it
and I've covered this report every
single year since they started putting
it out it is the Media Matters annual
report of how horrible the corporate
media did with their coverage of climate
change in 2018
in spite of the fact as Joe Rahm I think
progress points out in spite of the fact
that we received more bad news about the
future of the planet really than ever
before in 2018 network coverage of the
issue of climate change was actually
down last year it was down 45% from the
year before and it's not like it was
just oh we got a couple bad reports
showing us we've got 12 years left to
take action before we kind of hit the
point of acceleration on the issue no
it's the fact that we had 250 people
here in the United States die from
storms and other disasters fires that
made climate change we made so much
worse by climate change 250 people a
little more than 250 from just actually
three events two major hurricanes and a
major wildfire in California that raged
on for most of the year in different
parts all of these incidents were made
worse by climate change the three of
those alone accounted for more than 100
billion dollars worth of damage and yet
in spite of that the major networks ABC
NBC CBS and Fox devoted 45 percent less
of their coverage from the year before
to climate change last year to make
matters even worse the only reason that
number wasn't higher than 45 percent is
because NBC on Meet the Press at the end
of the year December 30th you know
really at the end of the year they
decided to run
they're full episode that week 45
minutes on nothing but climate change
good for them by the way but maybe try
doing that a few more times each year
considering this as an issue that
affects literally every single person on
the planet you'd think maybe it would
warn a little bit more coverage here's
the thing none of the network's news
reports on the major hurricanes of 2018
even mentioned climate change the major
storms not one mention of climate change
we have coverage was down for everybody
as I mentioned except for NBC because
they had that 46 minute episode on
climate change but what was equally will
equally worrisome was the lack of
solutions offered in these segments you
know Fox didn't offer solutions in any
of the five segments they devoted to
climate change but only 15 roughly 20%
of the coverage from the other networks
offered any kind of solution and here's
why that's a problem and we have seen
climate scientists you know Katharine
Hayhoe Michael man they've been more
outspoken about this recently because we
cannot just try to scare people into
wanting to do something about climate
change that doesn't work you can't just
say we're all gonna die in 12 years
unless you do something right now
no it almost has to be an inspiring
message of hope that there are solutions
that this is a fixable problem and
that's what drives me insane about it is
that it is a fixable problem and yes we
do have the technology available to
address it to get us off of fossil fuels
we just aren't implementing it and I
know everybody's going to say well that
requires major restructuring of our
power grids and our energy
infrastructure yeah it does and we do
have the technology to do that but we
had that technology for years and we
didn't do it so yeah I understand that
our grid can't handle it right now but
if we would have done it five years ago
health ten years ago the grid could
handle it
we screwed up we as a country as a
species yeah we screwed up that doesn't
mean the technology doesn't exist it
just means we didn't implement it and
now we're behind the eight ball but
there is still time and that's what's
missing for most of these reports
because you can't just go out there
anymore and say look bad things are
happening bad things are happening no
you have to say bad things are happening
but we can change it we have the
ingenuity we have the technology we have
the manpower and as a country here we
certainly have the money I look at
Donald Trump's budget boosting up the
military budget by tens of billions of
dollars what if what if we only took the
increase in military budget not even
touching the other seven hundred and
twenty billion dollars but just the
extra 30 or 40 billion and put that all
towards remaking our energy grid towards
a jobs program to get people out of
fossil fuel production and into solar
panels windmills you know geothermal
hydropower all kinds of different
programs we could retrain these workers
to work in those fields and I guarantee
you'd probably have a lot less people
dying of black lung but hey let's just
ignore all the solutions right let's
just keep doing business as usual
because some of us aren't gonna be
around when the really horrible effects
of climate change come to call so what
does it matter right it matters greatly
and it doesn't matter if you you know I
don't have kids I don't have to worry
about the future you do have to worry
about the future you have to because if
you don't you know that's almost a
sociopathic way to go through life you
cannot do that but the media is a big
part of the problem the media continues
to fail us and why do they do that well
essentially because they're paid to fail
us you've got these made
oil companies that no matter how
progressive a news organization is on
corporate media they're gonna take
fossil fuel money you're gonna see Exxon
ads you're gonna see BP ads you're gonna
see all kinds of ads from companies who
are profiting off the destruction of the
planet and until they get those ads off
the air they're gonna continue to ignore
the problem and not say that hey
solutions exist but before we get to
those solutions here's a word from Exxon
yeah not gonna cut it if you do it that
way